foreign
over in Dover Delaware didn't mean to
rhyme but I did it anyways Lisa how you
doing good how are you what's going on
so
we're 1662 and we have two cars and we
realize we don't need two cars and we
have two car payments so the one vehicle
has a lot of equity in it because of the
type of vehicle it is so we know we're
definitely selling that I I've got a
couple different options my husband
wants to sell that vehicle take the
proceeds and put it in our retirement
account
I want to get rid of both vehicles buy
the best car we can for let's just say
25 000 that way we have no car payments
and we can take that money and start
doubling up on our mortgage
um the only problem within the second
vehicle it's a hybrid so we got a 7 500
tax credit last year and if we dispose
of that car within three years we have
to recapture 66 two-thirds percent of
that 7 500. but my theory is if you have
no car payment
that recapture penalty will go away in
four four months so you'd lose out on
about five grand that you'd have to pay
back to the IRS right so my husband's
like I'm not paying the IRS well it
sounds like you guys are you're wanting
to do a lot of things at once you're
wanting to invest you're wanting to save
it you want to pay off the cars and so I
would focus on one thing at a time and
the best thing you can do right now is
to get out of all Consumer Debt so are
there two car loans your only debt or is
there other things uh there's a line of
credit on on the house you got a HELOC
how much is it
I want to say 30.
okay so we got how much what are the car
loans add up to
the Coraline I just looked at that I
just about fell out of my chair while I
was on hold
um there's 70 000. wow what's your
household income 150. that's a lot of
cars
yeah okay well I love the idea of
selling the cars and both of them yeah
the 5K while it hurts you could call a
stupid tax because that loan is going to
hurt you even more uh hanging on to that
thing so let's see here if you sold one
car
what would that give you the one that
has uh more equity in it that would give
us a 943 extra month all right and would
you clear any money is it worth more
than you owe oh yeah we'd probably clear
20. that's good okay and then what's
left on the other loan on the hybrid uh
that's a new one so that's 51 000 on
that oh wow sell these cars it was it
was a uh I don't know how midlife crisis
decision I made so it was stupid it was
definitely stupid I regret it it's fun
to drive but oh you know it's more fun
retiring yes when you want to what's
that it's more fun to retire when you
want to uh yeah my husband had a health
scare and that's kind of accelerated our
retirement too what are we doing and
let's let's ditch this debt and be able
to enjoy our life yeah I mean the
solution's right in front of you selling
these cars and and you sell both of them
you buy something that's within range
maybe you spend twenty thousand dollars
on something and then you you know
whatever you have have in this line of
credit clear that out
that's a much better situation than what
you're in today right
right it's just his his theory is he
does not want to pay back the stupid tax
you know he's like let's just hold on to
it we'll take the money that we had on
the other car and we'll just but he
doesn't see the film he doesn't see the
the 70k of car payments as stupid taxes
tonight because I think he doesn't yeah
I like I said I didn't realize so I
started pulling the financial
um you know the loan paper worked out
and I'm like tell them to listen to this
episode Jaden George told him that
that's the stupid tax if he was so keen
on investing he should have spent all
that money he spent on the cars and put
that into a retirement if he was such a
retirement fiend so I'm selling these
cars get rid of the HELOC next become
completely debt free get a fully funded
emergency fund then we can have a ball
investing that is the plan for progress
and you guys can get there with that
great income but we got to start
focusing today that's right thanks for
the call Lisa